you know i uh  with the help of others i developed a  scheme to um defraud the government out  of tax on every gallon of gasoline  and you know it was probably one of the  biggest earning  deals that we came across since the days  of prohibition it was tremendous amount  of money at the height of my operation i  ran it for almost eight years we were  bringing in eight to ten million dollars  a week coming into our operation  and uh it was very lucrative as a result  of that i was appointed a copper regime  or captain which was very powerful  position had a number of men under me i  was working with the russian mob they  were my partners in that scheme and we  were up and down the east coast  you know from new york all the way down  to florida selling gas we're selling a  half a billion gallons of gas a month  so it was a big operation and that kind  of propelled me into you know another  level in that life